hello everyone and welcome to a truly
outstanding game uh from the aimches u.s
rapid preliminaries it's already
versus magnus carlsen and it features uh
my favorite opening with black the
scandinavian defense another the line
that i enjoy but still it's a very nice
game and it's uh well it could go it
could have gone either way but the way
it went is definitely the the most
enjoyable so without further ado let's
check it out and see why i chose this
game to show alireza with the white
pieces opens with e4 we have d5 by
magnus going for the scandinavian
defense e captures queen captures and
now knight to c3 and i often mention
this uh there are usually uh three
popular retreats with the queen as your
queen is attacked here you could go to
d8 you could go to a5 you could go to d6
and even queen to e6 uh check has been
played i think magnus even played this
at one point maybe it was a blizz game
or a rapid game i don't know
but here we have queen to a5 if you're
interested about this queen to d6 line i
made a very nice uh well it's not a very
long video but it's a fun short video on
how to play this queen to d6 line so if
you want to check it out it will be the
first link in the description below but
here queen to a5 so this is the
basically the the most mostly played
line we have d4 and now knight to f6 we
have knight to f3 and bishop to f5 again
uh bishop to f5 and bishop to g4 are
both played it's it's a matter of
preference so you could try what you
know works best for you so here bishop
to f5 by magnus and the knight to e5 a
very nice um
tool against the most retreats of the
queen in the scandinavian
if the queen is on d6 or on a5 the
knight can easily come to c4 and gain a
nice tempo against the black queen so
here we have c6 uh the thing is if you
try something like e6 then it's very
easy to make progress with white we play
g4 attack the bishop here and once the
bishop owns the bishop to g2 and we put
pressure on this g7 pawn and gain uh
some nice development so here magnus
stops this by playing c6 right away and
now bishop the c4 by ferugia with e6 and
now g4
attacking carlson's bishop bishop to g6
and h4 so this is all been played before
many times uh nothing new here the
bishop is not in any danger of being
trapped you always have bishop to e4
followed by bishop to d5 uh knight beat
to d7 challenging whites knight and e5
and here knight captures and d7 we have
knight captures on d7 and now h5 forcing
the bishop to retreat to e4 so bishop to
e4 and now there are a lot of games that
reach this position uh rook to h3 is the
the move that can be played here there's
even a very nice game from 1997 from the
beale tournament anand versus joel
laudier uh where anand won a very nice
game with rook to h3 but here alireza
just castles and now as the knight is no
longer pinned uh the black is in danger
of losing the bishop so magnus moves the
bishop back and now we have knight
captures and d5 and c captures and e5
you don't want to capture with the e
pawn because then you allow white some
uh free tempi here so maybe not not the
way to go so instead c captures on d5
attacking white's bishop bishop to d3
and now magnus plays bishop to d6 again
this has all been played before
we have queen to f3 developing the queen
and now black uh
uh has some a couple of uh very
interesting moves here for example king
side castle is a normal queen the c7 is
a normal queen to d8 is a known move but
the move magnus plays has never been
played before and he goes queen side
castles and it is now only as a move 15
that we have a completely new game so as
usual when we have castles on opposite
sides of the board it's usually a race
and whoever strikes first will win the
game uh so here we have bishop to e3 you
could go for queen captures on f7 magnus
allows this but uh if you go for this
then magnus will play rook this rook to
d8 this rook to f8 and he's going to get
a lot of development in and well it is
interested in attacking on the queen
side not grabbing a pawn so instead
after magnus castle queenside we have
bishop to e3 now he's ready to play a3b
for c4 and try and bust open the queen
side we have g6 by magnus he of course
wants to open up the g file and alireza
prevents this by playing h6 we have rook
h to f8 now defending this pawn and at
some point probably e5 will be played
with a3 by alireza preparing b4 and c4
and now f5 by magnus so again he really
wants to open up some lines towards the
white king
and now c4 as we said this is a race and
whoever starts the attack first usually
wins the game
we have e5 by magnus now with the threat
of e4 which would win the bishop so b4
attacking black's queen queen to c7 and
now you can't really capture this pawn
because e4 is still a threat so c5
attacking the bishop here so now this
doesn't really make all that much sense
because we're going to capture the
bishop and we're still attacking the
queen so are you having a this double
attack here doesn't really do anything
so instead after c5 a magnet just
retreats with the bishop to e7 and now
we have bishop to b5 so now e4 no longer
attacks both the queen and the bishop
but magnus still plays it with e4 and
now queen to h3 the problem is if you
try something like queen to f4 to trade
off the queens uh it's uh just much
better for black for example captures
captures and now the bishop controls g5
we're gonna place g play g5 and after
the bishop moves we're gonna play f4 and
yes white does have a nice expansion on
the queen side but black structure here
is is just much better so instead after
e4 we have queen to h3 and now magnus
continues pushing with f4 we have bishop
to d2 and now you have to decide how you
want to continue this game whether you
want to play king to b8 get the king
away from the c file as it could open up
very soon or try something like rook to
f6 maybe gain more control over the c6
square and also allow the doubling of
the rooks on the f file magnus decides
on bishop to g5 so he gains more control
over the e3 square and he wants to play
e3 at some point
uh here we have c6 by alireza he has to
like i said it's a race you have to bust
open something
and now knight to f6 the problem with
capturing here on c6 is that although it
can be played it's very difficult to
play it rook ate the c1 now just
threatens to to win the c6 spawn in the
queen and after we defend it with rook
to f6 we can still capture it's not a
problem and after rook captures we're
going to play rook characters queen
captures and now rook f2c1 and black has
to give up the queen captures captures
and black could probably still play this
as he does have a monster pawn chain
here
it would be it would be very difficult
uh so instead after c6 we have knight to
f6 by magnus uh and now c captures on b7
with check we have queen captures on b7
and rook a to c1 with check king to b8
and now bishop to c6 putting pressure on
carlson's queen we have queen to e7 now
gaining more control over the e3 square
as that's why magnus plays the bishop on
g5 and now rook to c5 allowing white to
maybe double up on the c file rook the
b5 check can be played then rook and
come to b7 a lot of ideas here for white
uh magnus continues pushing uh well his
own agenda he plays e3 we have captures
captures and now bishop back to e1
you could also maybe throw in a rook to
b5 check first but you you i guess you
could always play that yeah so bishop
the e1 uh and now comes knight the e4 by
magnus here uh a nice attempt is a rook
to d6 it kind of prevents this whole
idea of rook to b5 checking to see it in
rook to b7 uh now you can block with
knight to d7 and it it kind of holds
so maybe maybe this is the the way to go
for black but magnus plays knight to e4
instead and now comes a very unpleasant
move from alireza and that is queen to
h2 with check so there are a lot of
moves black can play here but none of
them really work and i'm just going to
show a very fun line that seems to be
the most resilient one for black but
still uh kind of kind of insufficient
for example knight to d6 we block the
check like this rook captures on f8 rook
captures and now we uh attack the pin
piece bishop to g3 now attacking it once
more uh so you have to defend it rook to
f6 and now we capture on d5 now we were
attacking the knight three times and
also attacking the bishop here and now
black's best hope is bishop to f4 kind
of throw in this trick uh where if white
captures on f4 then we throw in pawn to
e2 and then black is just winning uh
because after a bishop captures on d6
we're going to capture with the rook and
the white doesn't really have a good
reply here e1 check is coming and that's
it we're gonna bring another queen into
the game not much for for white to do
here but what you could do uh instead
after this bishop to f4 move is just
play rook to e5 so whether this would or
would not have been played it's hard to
say but it's such a super fun line i
decided to show it because now you're
attacking the queen if uh bishop
captures then you're gonna capture with
the pawn attacking the knight and rook
and also the queen will no longer be
defending the e3 pawn so we would
probably see something like just queen
moves to f7 and now we capture on f4
rook captures on f4 and queen to g3
going after the e3 pawn rook captures on
d4
rook captures an e3 and now
white is just better here it does seem
like the white king is you know wide
open but after rook d1 check let's say
king h2 rook d2 check we can simply play
bishop back to g2 we could also go to h3
but then we have to allow queen to f1
check so we just go back bishop to g2
and we get this position where white
would uh well be much better
but
just wanted to show you what happens
with the knight to d6 idea that that's
seemingly most resilient but here magnus
played king to c8 and here he allows a
most thematic finish for alireza so feel
free to pause the video here and win the
game for alireza in the coolest way
possible there are two winning moves
here but i always try to get you guys to
find the most aesthetically pleasing one
so while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on always going
for that
beautiful beautiful move rook captures
on f8 is winning but here bishop to d7
check is the one that we were looking
for so now it's a double check from the
rook and the bishop and you don't really
have an option here if you move the king
to b7 then well the queen no longer
covers the c7 square we can deliver a
check king a6 and b5 is just checkmate
so what magnus did is of course he
captured the bishop but now comes rook
to c7 with check and now
although you could play king to e8 and
make the game go on a bit longer for
example rook captures queen bishop
captures rook and now queen to e5 and
the game kind of goes on but black is
completely busted magnus said uh well i
i better just give agamatra a nice
position for his thumbnail and he played
king the e6 allowing alireza to deliver
a checkmate in one which you all see as
you guys are incredibly strong players
uh so here alireza played queen to e5
and this is now checkmate which is
always uh
just uh very very enjoyable when players
of of these strengths uh allowed a
checkmate like this to appear on the
board and there we have it our nice
position from the thumbnail i even used
a nice yellow color for the king just so
you guys you know
get a nice feel for the position
uh so
that's the game a lot of you guys have
requested it and i'm very glad that you
did uh as it's uh well very very
enjoyable so keep using hashtag
suggestion i'm gonna go over your uh
suggestions and show the games that you
guys
enjoyed uh so i hope you guys enjoyed it
once again uh i would like to thank alan
goyet david kimura vladilaro mark
thompson and annie mccain for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
very nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day